a lot of people i guess i bring a lot of
inspiration to a lot of people that just
watch me and just like dude look at that
guy go what is what does prison teach
you
prison teaches you of self discipline of
uh
stand tall for who you are and your word
is your goals your word is your bond and
you know don't let nobody get you down
you know don't let no one get on your
skin you know
um
you know prison
you know
if they're not worth it to be active and
then all of a sudden just you know roll
it up because they're not with it to get
a
discipline
then
don't make the same mistake that you
made in you won't have this problem but
a lot of it's over you know a dictionary
i mean what i've seen is a lot of people
mature in prison big time and they grow
up and they just become like a better
version of the program is like you know
tvs don't come on until 10 o'clock and
roll up your mattress and read a book
for an hour and it's like my toy workout
month to friday saturday sunday day off
and for me it was workout monday to
friday saturday sunday handball all day
handball all day
and boy i've been playing hamilton's
five years old how many years have been
in prison
uh what 21 came out 35
21 came out 35 so that's almost like 17
years of my life i have been on seven
years of my life those were prime years
too yep
big time because 21 was like like boom
boom boom like what the big boy's like
damn here you are like this is it like
you know either you're in it or you're
gonna break you or you're gonna get
killed or you're gonna end up like oh i
can't take it anymore get rolled up out
of here or you know die in the system
but man by the grace of god you know
every day i just said god please one
more day just please let me
let me survive let me survive one more
day one more day
you know it's just and you've been out
how many years april 23rd 2014
14. so you've been out for a while it's
almost yeah and you're still learning i
gave them i gave the state three years
of being out and that three years i gave
them
without no direct drug tests pay off
restitution
hey they got me to itt tech dry college
for lead poisoning
i did uh six months in that graduated
and made a good job for a coleman
construction company 52 bucks an hour
man i never made it much never made that
much in my life
so it was a new beginning for me just be
like man you know career does pay off
but
you know i had my vehicle at the time
and uh when they went up north
you know carpools were already filled up
and i said don't jump you know when they
get a job in los angeles we'll give you
a call all right no problem but you know
the experience of just you know
learning new things of a new way of life
you know you're still learning things uh
as of today um
uh just basically where construction and
uh just the lead poisoning thing no but
i mean in life just so you still like
like some people have an appetite for
learning and other people are just there
well
they don't seem to care as as as far as
i mean i see you working out
you're one of the few people that
actually stays on skid row and works out
well as far as you know one take care of
yourself what my mistakes i did in the
past i don't want to make the same
mistake again and then end up right back
in prison and for the smallest dumbest
thing that i did over and over and over
again
today i just try to say you know what
that's not the life no more i don't need
to show anyone what i did or how i did
it i just just do me
but
it just so happens that you know
my life
i come a long way and i'm not trying to
get life in prison but
society itself is just like so much just
like
it's a dirty game dirty game it's like
they want to bring that
evil person out of you you're like
because you know they have no respect
for others or surroundings or for your
loved ones or nothing is so
you know i mean
someone can make me catch a case in this
and say no don't let them get on your
skin
it's just the priority in the principle
you know i mean it's like people come at
me right come at you right but
you know uh you know i uh i learned
today that uh
everyone that i you know i
did something wrong to you know karma's
gonna get me back in the end and here i
am in downtown l.a saying you know what
it's not over because i made amends to
everyone and
today i found me a new lady her name's
nicole
and
she's a sister
and i'm very very happy with her because
she's 28 years old
you know age is just a number
and um
and the time being with her
i always happen to get the ones that you
always get the one just have problems
and problems and problems and say you
know what i don't worry about that
because maybe i'm the one that helped
them clean up problems up and like thank
you for helping me out i think he would
do that after people get all mad and say
oh you're crazy sometimes you got to
learn how to adapt to their situations
of their you know their personality and
how they carry themselves but some
people just like you know you're a weird
ass lady hey you know what
if you like that then you're worth it
but if you want to help them to you know
kind of come to conclusion like you know
hey thank you for being there as a
friend
well
when she tells me that you know
her health are very are very very severe
like like like what like what
you know you know she needs a
kidney transplant i said whoa
and uh
a heart transplant
says damn
so
living in a ghetto lifestyle of fu and
all that [ __ ] all this all these
young hurt lungs again hey stop
calm down calm down and then she gets
you know gets all dizzy and then she
wants to you know
almost like pass out
all that stress and all that damn drama
your heart will just
just pop
and you know for
this young lady how her how she lived
her lifestyle
it was just beyond just damn
who's she with you know i mean like you
know you know because she's
there's no man has been restructured
properly because she thinks everything
is good what she thinks is i got myself
all over the place it's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa say come on you know we pick
up after ourselves
no no i don't live here like okay
you know where we come from we pick up
the rest of it it just came to a point
where i had to
you know
you know like you know let her know that
you know we conduct ourselves a little
more better than this you know i mean
and she's young yes but for her being
pregnant this would be her her first
child this is my number nine
i know what to do to take care of the
procedures you know i mean fluff with
the pillows here's your pineal peels
here's a little uh eggs and bacon and
whatever cereal
strawberries fruit and then
hold on i can eat that what i'm allergic
to
orange orange juice
ketchup
mustard
uh
lettuce peanut butter chocolate whoa
whoa whoa whoa i said damn all that
i'm just like
okay
so now i gotta watch
what i get and or if i make something
no tomatoes she can't you know it's it's
it's like almost like you know this
protocols i have to go buy it because
you get something like that she has
allergic reaction you know i mean it's
like oh well what happened you know i
mean i had to be very cautious and
her being pregnant i'm trying to tell
her you know
living in the streets of l.a
it's not going to be as pretty site you
know i mean you don't have a home
you don't have a restaurant to go to you
don't have a shower when you want to
shower you don't have a kitchen to go to
make something to eat you know what i
mean all you gotta do is ebt market ebt
market whatever the burrito bean cheese
burrito
uh
you know and i'm calling all these
people egg you know take a shower and
everything
if you cannot allow herself to
accept to get high and all this stuff
and
what are we gonna get out of this when
you know you and i'll i try to tell her
you of all people
how you could get pregnant in your
condition of your health wise
it's like a miracle baby you know be
careful what you pray for and we pray
for this
don't pray for something oh i'm not
ready yet and then you know what are you
doing you're doing all backwards you
know what i mean and you know what i
don't like ugly i'm trying to tell you
you know
you know i mean i'll help you i'll
support you but
you need to just you know the
surroundings who cares if they get high
who cares that this is a drug house
i say that it's easy for me but it's not
for them for just to be overnight and
stop like that cold turkey
not everyone thinks like you spooky
that's why i shut my mouth like damn
okay
you know
what do you need to do and then
you know
when you see someone
dibble dabbling in front of your face
it's like what is wrong with you you
know i mean you're destroying a
uh innocent child you know what i mean
and for my previous i told her from my
previous history i lost a first my first
son because she was smoking
methamphetamine
we had the ultrasound i'm sorry sir um
ma'am yeah there's no heartbeat hello
early pregnancy came out here you are
smoking smoking i'm gonna be okay i'm
like lady you don't know what the hell
you're doing to yourself you're being so
plea you're so petite so you know so
what five five and a half
five and a half that's how tall she is
you know i mean you you know you're so
skinny you're so petite but
you know
it's just like i'm trying to save you
so we don't have i don't have to go
through these things i'm sorry doctor
tells me
i'm sorry sir um get the baby lose the
mom or have the mom lose the baby no no
no no i don't want to lose nobody i lost
enough already how am i lose more people
now
it seems to me that that karma is like
god no i i pray every day you know keep
her strong
you know take care of her you know no
worries no stress we're okay
but you lost a lot of family members to
covet right yes how many yes i would say
about seven or eight
you know at one point there was so many
people in the house now it's only my uh
brother-in-law uh
my um
ex-ladies sister
old man taking care of two adopted kids
and three or three of his own
i was like wow the house is just totally
empty now
and uh
like i said um
i'm trying to say you know if i know
something to prevent something from
happening and then having a baby and
then they took the village i'm sorry man
this method fed me on this baby
you want to come home with the baby you
don't want to give the baby the system
you know what i mean that's like you
know didn't i tell you didn't i tell you
oh you didn't help me all that [ __ ] he
said she said all this it's like
i taught myself man i'm
battling
battling with the junior high kids it's
like woman listen i'm trying to prevent
this problem from happening
and it's just like it's really like
by the grace of god i just thank god
every day this you know stay strong
tomorrow's a new day tomorrow's a new
day and uh
you know
i don't want nothing happened to her i
how i tell her i keep my mind busy i
play handball right here i i work out
i get my money
because you don't know what's going to
happen
you know
i come a long way to be here today with
my freedom which i love i thank god for
but i have a chance to have a new
beginning a chance to what i what i
didn't do as a father when my daughter
was two years old in my hands
now that she's not in my life you know
whatever issues that she has against me
cool whatever but
i have a new beginning
i'm like trying to
weigh i'm trying to level it out like
now i gotta try to be a father again to
be there for the baby you know i mean
after she's out of the hospital you know
she's asleep i take care of the baby
this is my little occupation this is my
little priority right here you know i
mean now i got myself busy now have your
priorities changed as you gotten older
uh
yes because
like you were when you were 20 years old
you probably weren't ready to be a dad
uh
actually my first child i mean i had my
first child at 12 years old so i was one
my first show was 12 years old you were
12. yes
my daughter is 22 years old so my mom
goes you're better don't mind you know
what you better get into the mother mom
uh she was uh what i was 12 she was 14
wow you know so
i started real young so
you know um
my my my little son mike you probably
weren't ready to be a dad at 12 years
old exactly you know i was still young
and then you know gang banging i was
just like you know living the vida loca
but as far as you know going to jail
going to prison
you come out and
like i said you know it's going to make
you smart not dumb
you know it's not what you do is how you
do it and you know
from all my little drug habits i guess
praying on my knees asking god for
forgetting to take away the disease of
addiction
i don't have the craving for crack
cocaine no more see everyone's [ __ ]
crack i don't have no problem for that i
see people doing all this little crystal
and slamming
get your money get your money i got my
little my my uh mary jane and my little
alcohol here and there and hey i'm good
man i'm good you know what i mean i'm
i'm trying to uh make it to the top not
trying to go down no more man i'm tired
of failing but you know this whole this
whole
life has in store for us is so many
opportunities you know one door opens
one door closes
and if i could get a chance with you
know with all the support out here that
don't tell me to write a book or you'd
be good for uh uh 187 more death kill or
fascinating fears cholos or whatever
i appreciate all the support from all
from everybody man you know and uh
it's it's just
it's it's time for a change for myself
and for my new families i'm i'm about to
have and
you know it's being responsible and
taking care of my priorities and like i
said i don't have no worries in sight
because
when you worry about the smallest thing
in life man
just chill out man it's not the end of
the world i mean you know
you know we try so hard then you get
frustrated because you don't work the
way you want to but you just gotta learn
how to just
just just kick back and lay like a cholo
man you'll be all right you know
but uh
i just want to thank you guys for
everything and
have a blessed one spooky i'm happy for
you thank you brother good luck
all right thanks
you